Russia has officially launched direct
passenger train service to the annexed
territory of Crimea using a route that
bypasses mainland Ukraine people can now
travel from saint-petersburg southwards
toward the Crimean city of Sevastopol
the journey lasts forty four hours and
crosses the Crimean bridge which Moscow
is accused of building illegally Russian
President Vladimir Putin rode along a
section of the route on Monday to
inaugurate the railway Moscow sees
Crimea from Ukraine in 2014 I move that
strong international condemnation the
new train route is seen as a fresh step
to cement Russia's grip on the region
let's get the latest on this story our
correspondent Emily Sherwin is standing
by in Moscow hi Emily
why is this new train service so
important to Vladimir Putin well suit me
as you said the move Russia has moved to
annex the Crimean Peninsula in 2014 was
condemned widely by the international
community but here in Russia it's seen
as a patriotic victory and in a way this
bridge is kind of a concrete
manifestation of that Russia Russians
after all see the Crimean Peninsula as
theirs during the Soviet Union it was a
popular holiday destination and the
peninsula was actually gifted by
Khrushchev to Ukraine in 1954 when it
didn't really matter when it was all the
Soviet Union and so people here really
celebrated the annexation the illegal
annexation of that Peninsula in 2014 as
a defiant move from Vladimir Putin he's
very much seen as a symbol of kind of
Russia standing against the West defying
the West and actually that annexation
led to a huge spike in putin's putin's
ratings as well one that he could need
at the moment with surveys showing that
trust is that a historic low in in
Vladimir Putin my house is all being
covered by Russian media well the
coverage of this opening today has been
rather bombastic we saw Vladimir Putin
kind of traveling across the bridge we
saw presenters referring to that footage
today
on TV as a historic moment just last
year Vladimir Putin opened kind of road
traffic on the bridge he actually drove
a truck across the bridge now we see him
in that in a train he was addressing as
well workers today the workers that
build that built this bridge in as
people here say record time and he was
saying that this is a symbol that Russia
really can do everything and anything at
all Emily we mentioned that people
accuse Moscow building that bridge
illegally I mean how is this being seen
internationally
well this bridge is seen by the US by
the EU and by Ukraine as well as a
violation of Ukraine's sovereignty of
course Ukraine sees the bridge as
illegal in the sense that people
passengers will be entering entering
what they see as Ukrainian territory via
the Russian mainland so that's kind of
against against international law and
there have been sanctions as well
against Russia starting in 2014 for the
annexation and for Russia's involvement
in supporting separatists in eastern
Ukraine as well and the EU has just
prolonged those sanctions for another
half a year but it seems today from that
footage that we've seen and from this
opening from this these train journeys
that we're seeing this defiance that
Russia is certainly going to stand its
ground when it comes to Crimea GWS Emily
Sherwin covering this story for us from
Moscow thank you